thank you very much i thank the
organizers for the nice opportunity of
talking in this very nice workshop
so as the title suggests i will talk
about two things second varieties and
interpolation but mainly actually i will
talk about interpolation so i will start
by recalling the definition of second
variety i will spend a few words to tell
you how to translate the problem of
computing dimensions of second varieties
to certain projected varieties that we
have seen in this workshop into some
interpolation problem then we will
mainly discuss interpolation more
general interpolation problems and at
the very end of the talk
we will see how secant varieties
naturally show up again when doing
interpolation so
maybe the structure of my talk is the
following i start with second varieties
and then we go along a loop talking
about interpolation
and then
we come back again to second varieties
at the end so just to see how these
objects geometric objects are very well
connected so
let me start by well writing once again
the definition of secant variety we all
know it but mainly i want to fix my
notation
so
if x
is a non-degenerate
projective
variety
that in some projective space p capital
n by non-degenerate i mean that it
doesn't live in a hyperplane so it feels
the linear span fills up the the whole
space
what is the secant variety i like this
notation sigma s
of x this is defined to be
the elements the points q
the ambient space bn
that
leaves in a s minus one projective space
in the span of s distinct points p1
and ps
with pi
easting points of x
but then i also want to take limits of
this s minus one place so it takes the
there's a risky closure in terms of ten
sorts or rank of tensors these are the
elements in
again with border rank at most yes
so what are the varieties well this is a
general definition but actually we focus
on some particular examples so what are
the fundamental varieties for this talk
well
first of all the segregated variety x
can be a segre
variety
so this would correspond to tensors like
q
tensors in a tensor space a one tensor
tensor a n
so these are several varieties but also
we will consider veronese
varieties
and these correspond to symmetric
tensors so polynomials
but i can also combine these two objects
and take segre embeddings of the
products of varying varieties so these
are the so-called segre
veronese
varieties and these in terms of tensors
if they correspond to skew symmetric
sorry partially symmetric tensors
what is the main question that we are
going to address is to compute the
dimension of the secant variety to
this kind of projective varieties so the
question the main question
that we are going to
try
that we are going to discuss
is computing
the dimension of sigma s
of x
where x is in this list
well what is the main tool that one uses
in order to try and answer this kind of
question this has been discussed already
in the tutorials on monday morning it's
teratini lemma
so i'm now actually as i promised i'm
now translating this problem into an
interpolation problem using using
terracinilemas so what does
terracinilema say well in the same
notation as above x is an undegenerate
projective variety in a projective space
then i take now i take a point q
in the sigma s of x
a general point
so q
lives in the span of s
points of x
so p i
in x
so if i want to take
well if i want to compute the dimension
of
this variety i might as well take a
smooth point and compute the dimension
of the tangent space to that variety at
that point that's the same number so
this this is the object that i'm
interested is the the tangent variety
the tangent space to the secant
varieties at the point q
well teratini lemma states that this is
equal to the linear span of the tangent
spaces to the variety x at the given
points p1 and ps
t x
v 1
d x
b n p s
so when one wants to compute this
dimension he can
compute the dimension of this linear
span so for instance if i take
the twisted cubic
like this
in this basin p3
this is the third verniers embedding of
the projective line by the way so if i
want to comp if i want to take a point
uh q on the secant variety i'm taking a
point on a line
so i want to compute the tangent space
to this point q at this point q to the
variety well what i do is i take the
tangent lines maybe i should use colors
the tangent lines to
the points p1 and p2
and they just compute the linear span of
these lines
and this by terracinilam is going to be
my object
so i can take
this line
and this other line which is q and they
will spawn a p3 well they will actually
span the entire space so this this is
this proves
that the the the
second variety this variety of second
lines to the twisted cubic is indeed the
whole space so that's a pictorial
proof of this fact but of course one can
do this in general
but
let's continue
we didn't get to the linear system
setting yet so let's do that now so
let's
l
curly l b
line the line bundle
that embeds x my variety x in my
projective space bn so something for
which
is wedding then i take
the projectivization of the global
section x0xl
i guess i should take some
star somewhere well that's my pn so
let's fix
line bundle that gives me this map and
in in my examples segre veronese and
sega veronese variety that's very easy
to see who this bundle is is actually so
in the case of segre
so
several embedding of p and one
times
p
and r
the line bundle that i'm considering is
o of one one one
so it's a line bundle of multi-degree
one one one one on the product of
projective spaces in the case of
veronese
i take the d th veronese embedding of
the nth projective space then the line
bundle that i have to take in order to
get this embedding is
o of
b and
d so i just take the structure shift and
i twist it by t
that's what i got and in the case of
sega veronese well that's very easy to
figure out by looking at these two
examples
in the case of segregate just take l to
b
it has to be a multi-graded a
multi-degree line bundle and now i'm
adding instead of once i take degrees
that's that's the very laser part of
this embedding so that's i just write we
want
r was the number of factors
okay so having said so when i have this
line bundle now i want to understand how
to relate it to the dimensionality
problem for second varieties
so
the point is that there exists
a bijection
between
the hyperplanes
as follows from terracinilema the
hyperplanes of
pn containing
the tangent space to the second variety
at given points
this is in correspondence with elements
of
the following bundle so i take l
and i twist it by the ideal shift of s
double points
the the other points are the one that
i'm taking so p leaves on the span of s
points and then i just take
the power two so i just take this
i let me denote it p1
square
ps
square so who are these guys this well
for instance in the case of the veronese
so when so l is given by basically is
the vector space of homogeneous
polynomials of degree d in n plus one
variables and when i twist it by this
i'm just asking
that i'm just taking those who actually
vanish with multiplicity two at the
given points so that's an interpolation
problem because and now i'm asking
who is the space of polynomials of
degree d vanishing with multiplicity to
at a given collection of points well
this correspondence follows from from
terracinilema and basically this is this
is one or two
they are or orthogonal to each other
because
this um the tangent space
the tangent space to x at p i contains
the derivation that will kill my
polynomial f in order to say it
interpolates that point with
multiplicity 2. and then i take all of
them i have s points and i take all of
them and that's how i get this
correspondence
elements of
what do you mean when you say elements
of
well that's okay so this is a linear
system but i can think of it this is a
line bundle but i can consider the
corresponding linear system and i can
think of it as a vector space
in the case of veronese for instance i
can think of it as
as a vector space of homogeneous
polynomials of degree d where d is the
order of the veronese embedding in pn so
hypersurfaces of pm
yeah
and then and then if i want to consider
well the segregated then this will be
polynomials with multi-degree
d1 dr
and then again i'm imposing the
vanishing of partial derivatives all
partial first order i just was wondering
how you're right
literally a hyperplane does not
correspond to a point
in the total space of a bundle that's
yes
yes section of that yeah yeah yeah such
sex the h0 of that i mean sections of
that yeah i'm yeah
i'm abusing notation so
this
tells me that
well the co-dimension
this correspondence tells me that the
dimension of the sigma s of x well keep
in mind that x is one of these three
guys of course one can do the same
taking any hyperplane sections of of any
variety and then imposing
double points but that this is what we
are interested in studying
segregation so this tells me that the
co-dimension of the secant is equal to
the dimension of that linear system
so this is equal to
dimension of l
twisted by v one s sorry two
so that's how i translate my
dimensionality problem for second
varieties to a dimensionality problem
for linear systems so this is an
interpolation problem with double points
and actually all
all classification results or even
partial results about dimensions of
second varieties to these kind of
objects have been proved by means of
these correspondence so all the results
as far as i know all the results have
been translated all the this
problems have been translated into
interpolation problems on double points
and solved in that setting and then and
then you get the dimension of the second
variety and let me list what is known so
far
about this
so well the
most celebrated
result is the so-called alexander
birchowitz
theorem this deals with the ronese
variety so they completely classify
second varieties to veronese varieties
and the way they do is they completely
solve the interpolation problem for
hypersurfaces of the projective space
with any collection of general points
these points are in general position
they maybe forgot to
say so they completely well i'm gonna
write this when the classification is
complete so i'm not gonna so they prove
that
the dimension is always the one that you
would expect except in a finite list of
cases that i'm not gonna write now
there's another for
concerning segreg varieties there's
another complete result due to
catalyzano
geramita and gimignano
well this this dates back to the 90s
actually alexander and the issue then
later on there were
simplified and shorter proofs the
original proof is 150 pages long or
something like this
and then it was simplified by many other
authors but another now talking about
maybe yeah maybe just right veronese
interpolation problem in pn and then
another complete result is by catalyzano
geramite emiliano in 2011
and they completely classify segreg
embedding
of products of projective lines so any
number of factors but all of all of them
be ones this is also
solved now again in terms of
postulation of double points of
interpolation on double points
so though all cases are non-defective
but one i think with five four five five
five five thanks four four factors okay
thank you and then about okay this was
this is for segre four
different segregation with bigger spaces
there's a conjecture you can find the
conjecture on a paper by
uh about aviany peterson but that's
still open i mean maybe there are some
partial results but it's still still not
known
so
exceptional cases are known but the
difficult part is to prove that all the
other cases are non-exceptional
but
what about
the
yeah yeah indeed i'm yes yes for the two
two factors is no they are all
three
three factors is known
segre
okay
all the same all the same dimension okay
ah all the same dimensions okay
that's of course yeah yeah yeah yeah but
p a cross b b cross pc this is still you
know
no
yeah
right this is what
we computed some pa cross
yes
pc
the first yeah i think it was p one p
one p two
yeah yeah low cases of course i mean
this all these proofs are done by
induction so when by induction on the
degree in the case of rhones and only
dimension and by induction on the number
of factors in this case so when you want
to do induction you need to know the
initial steps first and it's always very
useful to use
for a computer like macaulay do to to to
just solve all these cases by hand and
also to get like a
an intuitive
idea of how it's going to be later on
with higher parameters but let me just
briefly continue this this is just an
historical let's say overview but this
is not exactly what i'm going to talk
about so in the case of sega veronese
there are
also few results known in the case of
two factors
so
there are a couple of papers by
i think baliko
alessandra
they classify
all these cases p1
cross pn
with by degree
penny by degree so this is also
completely classified
and also
yeah
again alessandra
enrico who was here last week carlini
and catalizano again they
gave some partial classification for the
case of pn
times pm
but with by degree
and something and this is partial
it's not completely solved in the three
factor case
there's
there's a work by
uh hiro and cara brambila
they
recently found new defective
new defective cases in this setting for
segre veronese
new
defective cases
that's a complete classification
classification is far from being known
another uh
complete result is about segre
veronese
embedding of
products of projective lines p1
cross p1 any any number of factor this
is also and and any multi-degree
p1 the
r
and this
this is due to laface and
myself that's also a complete result and
also in this case we did it by studying
postulation of double points on products
of projective lines
okay
but
yeah so i guess in the list of exercises
that i proposed for the problem sessions
i gave some particular cases of this
yeah i don't know how i don't remember i
think i asked to compute the dimensions
of the second varieties using macaulay 2
of p2 times p2 and p2
sega veronese of p2 times p2 with a
given by degree i think it was two two i
don't know but any anyway when the when
the parameters are low like in these
cases that i'm mentioning of course you
can solve it by may call it two and
that's why why we are here
so okay so
so this is as i said all of these were
sold by by means of postulation of
double points but what about
generalizing in this direction so
forgetting the second variety setting
for the moment and instead
trying to solve interpolation problems
for higher multiplicities
so can we do that can we
yes we can and that's what we i'm gonna
talk about in this talk
can you just say before we erase the
center board um just give the example of
the two double points why it comes out
in this case just for the sake of people
haven't seen it before
get it
which example i mean so this this
corresponds to the bijection in the
cases which is cubic
why is it that tera chinese lemma show
says that you need two double points
well yeah so
for the graduate students is what i'm
saying because i know not everybody has
seen this bijection yeah okay so the
point now i'm not even sure i'm able to
write down the details but the point is
that you fix a point you fix a point on
the cubic on the on the twisted cubic
and that's the polynomial that's a
monomial that's the power of a linear
form of degree d in
degree 3 actually in
in two variables and then you want to
take the tangent space to it so
basically it's given by so if
l to the three is my elements on c3
that's the twisted cubic mp
p3
then if you want to consider the tangent
space
uh
sorry at that point i might as well just
write it
then this is given by monomials of the
form l to the two times
g
some other stuff
and then and then you want well then you
want to do it for more points like for
instance for two points in this case and
then you ask who are the
so if you go into the dual um coordinate
ring so you take the ring of derivations
then you ask who are the derivations who
kill
who kill my so you have to yeah to take
first order derivatives in order to
understand the tangent space and taking
first third first order derivatives
means imposing a double point so asking
that my polynomial of such degree in
such variables vanish with multiplicity
2 at a given point so not only it has to
vanish at the point but also its first
order partial derivatives have to
okay so and then of course we can as i
was saying generalize this construction
and ask for higher multiplicities so i'm
asking that not only the first order
partial derivatives vanish at my given
point but
all partial derivatives up to a given
number that i can fix
so
higher multiplicity
okay so what i'm doing now well now i
stick to the veronese case so actually
i'm taking p2
a sorry pn so now i take pn and i fix
integers d
m1
ms and i
make sure that these bigger than all of
the other integers these are actual
number
and then
these are going to be this is going to
be the degree and these are going to be
the multiplicities at a collection of s
points so i take p1 ps
npn
general points
points in general positions so i don't
want three of them on a line i don't
want six of them on a conic and so on
they have to be general
and i
introduce this notation l
to be
depending on all of these parameters and
d m one up to m s
so i'm writing l and d
and one
ms
so this is my
object of study and this is
just the vector space of homogeneous so
we work over c of the complex numbers
we want to consider all homogeneous
polynomials of degree d and n plus one
variables they will give me a
hypersurface of pn
that's
such that
if i take
the derivative of order any derivative
of order m i minus one
and i evaluate of f and i evaluate it's
at the point
p i this is 0 for all i
from 1
so what i'm saying is that okay i take
my homogeneous polynomial of degree d
and i ask that it vanishes at the point
well actually i'm asking that the
m minus one derivatives vanish at the
point but that's enough i mean because
this is homogeneous so that's enough
considering the last the highest order
of derivation if i want to take the fine
version then i need to i have one
less variable and then i need to ask for
the previous derivatives but that's we
stay with the homogeneous notation so
that's enough and the question is
how many of these polynomials do i have
so what is the dimension of l
well there's a naive answer
that is just given by a parameter count
because of course i know exactly how
many polynomials of this degree in this
number of variables i have and i know
exactly how many derivations i mean i'm
imposing so this is a linear system of
equations in the coefficients
of
of my polynomial so i can easily count
how many of this polynomial should
survive after this killing with the
derivatives so that's
this actually gives a lower bound
to this answer and that's what we call
the virtual
dimension
denoted it by
the dim of l
that's just the num the difference
between the number of homogeneous
polynomials of degree t and plus t
choose n
minus and then for every point
i want that all the derivations of order
m i minus one vanish so
how many conditions do i have n plus m i
minus 1
so
so this is
always
less or equal than the actual dimension
because what can happen is that so if
this these are linear equations that i'm
imposing that's a linear system of
linear equations but some of them may be
that there may be some relation among
them they may be not linearly
independent in that case the dimension
would be bigger i would have less
conditions some of them will be just
a linear combination of the previous
ones so this this gives me a lower
bounds
and then
i say that if
well let's just take
non-empty objects
so let's assume that there is actually
something in this linear system that
there exists some polynomial satisfying
this interpolation condition
i say if
the dimension is strictly bigger than
the expected dimension
then i say that l
is special
effective
so when the conditions are not linearly
independent and what they want to do in
this talk is to actually compute the
speciality so compute the difference
between these two numbers so let me just
call it h1 i'm going to briefly say why
i use this notation for the difference
between dim of l
and the electrical dimension of l why do
i take h1 well it's because i use
algebraic geometry in order to prove it
so that's actually the
dimension of of the first chromology
of my linear system so the point is that
but i'm not gonna go into details i just
want to justify
this notation that is not completely
crazy well it may be but
um
so the point is that what i want to do
is to
blow up
my projective space in my points so i
considered p
they blow up at p1
ps
of pn
on pn i have this linear system given by
this formula this and then i just take
the pullback of it so i take the strict
transform
of element inside there and it turns out
that the euler characteristic of this
is actually equal to the virtual
dimension
it is exactly one can prove that it is
exactly that number is not very
difficult
but one can also prove that well this is
the alternating sum of the dimensions of
the homology groups but one can also
prove that only h0 and h1 are important
all the higher cosmology varnish for
free
so
just please accept it that's not
difficult to prove so
the with virtual dimension is the
difference between the h0 and the h1 but
what is the h0 well that's just the
dimension
is the dimension of this linear system
seen as vector space as co homology yeah
so so the speciality is h1 that's why i
i call it like this but let's let's
proceed
with the with some examples because what
i'm gonna do is to instead rather than
proving non-specialty results i'm gonna
prove speciality results so i'm
interested in the special cases so let's
just start by seeing some of them
so for instance in p2 so in the planes
i'm considering linear linear series of
curves
and i fix a degree i just take the first
non-trivial one two i take conics conics
planar conics and then i fix two points
two distinct points with both of them
multiplicity two
so
well i can use my formula my naive
parameter count
and say what is the virtual dimension of
this guy so what is the expected image
what do i expect it to be how big it is
so this number is zero
because i have in total six conics
in p2 and then each double point will
give me three
it's point plus the two tangent
direction so these are the three
derivatives so that's zero is six minus
three minus three is zero but actually
so
if i draw two points distinct points in
the plane then i can consider the line
connecting them and then i can just use
bazoo theorem to see what is the
intersection what is the intersection
number between this line and a general
cubic sorry conic in in my
if i is
yeah let's just write l
intersection with l where l is this line
and i get minus two that's just bezu so
this tells me that the line is con i
mean the line is contained i get a
negative number so the line is contained
and it's contained with multiplicity too
so actually so what does it mean that
there do exist a conic which is singular
into double point this conic is singular
along the whole line it's the double
line that's a conic a double line is
iconic it's singular along the whole
line in particular at the two points so
this is an element in my linear system
so this proves that
the dimension
l is actually one but it was supposed to
be zero so the speciality is one
that's okay so you can say okay this is
kind of a very easy example i mean
does this happen also for higher degree
do do i get this line
such a configuration like this yes let's
let's see this other example i take
degree six sex sticks in the plane and i
take points
one again i take two points with
multiplicity four
so i can compute
the typical dimension
this is going to be eight that's just an
easy parameter count
but
let's let's think about
it a little bit so i have
two points in the plane and i want to
consider a sex stick
which has multiplicity four
i again do the same trick as before and
it turns out
that the double line not only the line
but the line twice has to split off the
system it has to be contained in all of
the elements like this
so an element a sexting inside here is
not irreducible it is the reduced union
of a double line and something else
and something else that looks like this
so a quadric so the degree was six i
remove a double line i get degree four
and it has to go through the points
twice more so this is
so the dimension of l is equal to the
dimension of the linear system of
quadric a cortex sorry with two double
points and that
has dimension nine
so again
i get
that the dimension is not what i
expected the h1 is again one but i have
again a double line so is it always the
case that whenever i have a double line
that splits off the system it will give
me a speciality
which is equal to one
yeah
it is it's at least one but it could be
even bigger yes yes yes in this yeah
yeah it is at least one it could be even
bigger but it is it will be one yeah
okay but i can also so
i can also what about other curves i
mean now we get a line that splits off
what about i take i get other different
curves that splits
off my system and that's also a famous
example so
i take degree 4 in p2 i take cortex in
p2 with five
double points
and again i do the parameter count and i
get that it should
i should be empty i should not have such
a quartic
but we all know that if i fix
five general poi these points are in
general position if well yes they are
not not three of them on a line so we
all know that through five points
general points of p2 i always have a
conic
sonic that looks like this
but then
i can take the double conic
and that's something of degree 4 which
is singular everywhere in particular it
is singular the six points five
so that's again an element inside here
so
the dimension is actually one i do have
one element
i do have one polynomial that satisfies
my
interpolation conditions and again
i get speciality equal to one
exactly as for the line so it seems that
whenever i have a curve which is twice
doubly contained
in the base logo so it's fixed
in the in the with multiplicity two in
the in the base it's a fixed component
of multiplicity two of my linear system
it seems that it creates troubles and
how to quantify these troubles it seems
to be exactly one so
so the question is is it
this next at least in the planner case
is this the answer to my
can this helps somehow to answer
interpolation problem
explain the speciality
of linear systems
well
an example of d equals six then you're
saying that the sex sticks which have
two quarter points that
uh better fat like four
is actually a different variety it's a
variety of cortex with double points to
union another variety of wines the same
satisfy that property is actually the
variety of sex sticks that that split
yeah it's not the varieties it's a
linear system so the point is that you
write your
all the sextings has to be have to be
written like two times the line plus
l prime where l prime is the linear
system of
four ticks with two double points
and they have to be the same they have
the same dimension and that's how you
compute it that's that's it so so we
have seen that whenever you have a curve
a rational curve with
higher multiplicity high enough in the
base locus then this will give me h1 and
actually in general it's
it's easy to prove that what easy i mean
one can prove that if there exists a
rational curve
let's call it
c containing p2 such that
the intersection number
with my linear system is at most
negative two like it was in the cases it
was exactly minus two and moreover well
i also require that the normal bundle
let's just just a technical done task i
mean let's
move on there's just a technical
uh
extra condition
i wanted to have the same normal bundle
as a line but i wanted to say that it's
one can see that whenever there's a
curve
behaving like this then the linear
system l is special
this is the easy this i mean it's not
easy but one can handle it but the point
is that there's a conjecture a
well-known conjecture due to sergey
harbour gimiliano and birchovitz
here
i'm sure i'm expelling some name anyway
so that conjecture that that's actually
an ethanol if so whenever a system is
special it's because of the presence of
such
a curve in the base locus and this is
known to be true
in some cases but it's still open in
general so this conjecture is known to
be true whenever i have at most
nine points
and this
shoes
a series of work by by these three
authors show that this is actually
so in that case you can get a rational
cue
cubicle
when that's as large like i say
i uh rational cubics should not create
speciality but normal yes that's a
normal condition so that that would say
you probably only get harder
and then yeah so one yeah so one setting
under which this is true is when you
bound the number of points but then you
let the multiplicity be as high as you
want
but also it's true for every number of
points and bounded multiplicity
12 i think
and this was proved by more recently by
chili berto
and miranda
and they used a very complicated
degeneration arguments and that was yeah
to prove that
this conjecture is true up to
multiplicity 12. otherwise it's open
but of course one can use macaulay too
and find some nice examples and
instances where the trajectory is true
but
okay so
so far we have talked i mean i
introduced the problem in full
generality so here we were in pn
but we only talked about the planar case
what i'm actually going to do now is to
move to the higher dimension
dimensional case
so
not only we will see lines splitting off
my system but we will see higher
dimensional sub-variety that will create
speciality and we want to try to
describe them at least detect
who they are and try to understand how
much
they contribute to the specialty
so that's our main next task
so
the idea well yes let's say the plan
is to do the following
first of all we need to prove
to understand
the pain's locus
oh well
because in higher dimension i will see i
will see curves but i will also see
bigger
higher dimensional stuff so i cannot
talk about fixed components these are
not divisors
that will be like any possible dimension
between one and
co dimension one
um but then so i want to understand who
is actually in the base locus of a given
in a system
but and and i want to understand
which of the cycles of the base locus
actually creates a speciality so
identify
components
of b
s l
that
produce
speciality and these are what we call
special effect
varieties
this why this terminology was introduced
by bocce in his phd this is also
obstructions
this i guess was introduced by chandler
well anyway these are these are objects
that are in the base locus but they are
in the base lock with multiplicity high
enough in order to give each one such as
the double line and the double chronic
the single line is in the best local but
it's not special effect the double line
is
same for the conic and then yeah third
is compute
h1
so why do we get exactly one for a
double line
okay so this is the plan and let's start
with the easier
uh
case so let's consider the linear
base locus so let's consider the
cycles of the base blocks which are
linear subspaces of my
projective space bn
so i'm going to talk about linear
special effect varieties
linear
special
effect
such as the line there
and this is joined
with
maria chiara brambila and
okay so
okay so first of all we want to give a
base locus lemma so let's
fix
an index set i 1
i r plus 1. so we want to identify who
are
i mean here we saw the line but of
course if i have more points in a bigger
space i can take a plane span it by
three points rp3 given by four points
these points are in general position so
they will always
span a full dimensional um
projective space inside the big project
space so let me parameterize these
spaces these objects so i take i
and a multi-index that is contained in
1s so i'm just choosing
r plus 1 of my points
and
i will introduce this number k of i
to be well i take
the sum of the m i's the sum of the
multiplicities
of my points
that are parameterized by this set i
that i fixed
minus r d
so i fixed this number
i will explain why i got this number but
i'll take this number and then
okay
and the lemma
based locus lemma
that's the first thing that we have to
do
if
k
i
is bigger or equal than 1 if this number
turns out to be positive
then
the linear subspace l i which is
just the linear span of p
i
with i and i
okay so if i have two points this is a
line
if i have three points this is a plane
and this is l one two three that's a
plane
so if this number is positive this plane
is contained or this uh linear cycle is
contained
in the base locus of l
with multiplicity
yeah let me write at least k i
well
if r is one i'm just taking two points
and that's exactly the intersection
formula here
m1 plus m2 minus d this is what you get
here and then of course you can use
induction and iterate this bezu uh
problem this bezel theorem in order to
get the same corresponding number for
for for for like a plane for instance
because now if i if i have a plane i
have three points i want to understand
what is the multiplicity of containment
of that planes then i just first of all
take a line i know by bazoo it can
intersect a line with a hypersurface and
i get
a number right so this will tell me the
multiplicity of containment of the line
but then if i want to consider the whole
plane then i just take
a point on that line and the and the
other point
and
so
if i already know this line
and they want and i ask what is the
multiplicity of the plane now i take
this
extra point
and i take the line connecting
that point with the with the point on
the line of course the union of all
these planes of all these lines will
give me my plane
so by iterating what i said before i can
compute the multiplicity of containment
of this dashed dashed line and this is
going to be the multiplicity of
containment of my plane and you get this
formula
so
that's it's not very difficult
so this is the first task
so we know that whenever this number is
positive that corresponding linear cycle
is contained with at least that
multiplicity
but then
uh yeah that was one point but then
which of them
are actually special effect for my
linear system
for instance the line was special
effects only when k
the corresponding ki was at least two
so in general this is the same
for higher dimensions so whenever ki
is the dimension of the cycle plus one
so two in the case of a line three in
the case of a plane this is special
effect
l i
is
special effect so not only it is in the
base locus but it also produces
h1 speciality
and the third thing is to see how much
it produce i mean what is the h1 that it
gives
so it contributes
to the h1
by and then i'm gonna write the formula
minus 1 to the r plus 1
times
n plus k i
minus r minus 1 choose n
here is its contribution so in the case
of a double line
this this is a positive sign
and this would be a 2
so you would have
n plus 2 minus 2
choose n
1 and that's exactly what we got but
then you can do the same for higher
demand i mean this is
this is the formula that you get so
if the line is more multiple it will
give it will give more multiplicity more
uh a speciality and if the yeah and the
same for higher dimensional stuff and
then you have a plus minus thing
depending on on
on the
on the dimension on the dimensions so
this
yells a new definition a new lower bound
well a new definition of
uh
expected dimension this is what we call
linear expected dimension
for my linear system
it follows from this base locus lemma
because i know that whenever this is
satisfied and in particular whenever
this number is big enough i know that my
system is special
and i can now also compute how much
specialities with this number so i can
give a new formula for the expected
dimension which is just the old one plus
the sum
let me call this
l of i
this number that i get and then i just
take the sum
over all eyes
over all linear subspaces and that's
and that's yeah and that's um
let's see an example
yes
i'm very sorry
could you recall what was r it was r is
just a number of points
that i'm taking so r is here
so i just fix r plus one points
i do this trick for computing the
multiplicity of containment so i iterate
the zoo it's an induction argument i
know it for lines because i can
intersect the line with the hypersurface
and then i can
if i know it for the line i also know it
for this line so i know it for the whole
plane
and so on
so uh
this is something that's like turns out
to be true in the in the proof let's say
that you have to have this number big
enough but you see it right because if
this number ki was smaller then this
would just be zero
so this number you actually get by means
of
restricting so the point is that i'm not
doing it now but the point is that
i said at the beginning that you study
this interpolation problem and use in
order to use the direct geometry one
should blow up
the space in the points but now if you
want to deal with linear cycles you also
want to blow up these linear cycles and
this turns out to to be like the
yeah some chromology of
when you restrict your divisor divisor
to your linear system to
it doesn't make sense i don't want to
talk about it but that's just uh how it
is so let's um
i'm just going to show you an example
and then i want to move to some more
interesting obstructions so for instance
in the case
of cubics
of p3 with three triple points
so
the visual dimension
one does the computation and is negative
is minus 10 but we know that if i have
three points
it'll be three
and then i can consider i can consider
the plane i'm going to draw the plane
like a triangular as i did this reminds
a little bit of the polytope of a b2
historic geometry so
the plane spanned by the three points
one can
see with this formula that is going to
be contained with multiplicity three so
actually if i take that that plane three
times this is an element it has degree
three and it has multiplicity three at
the three vertices so actually this
shows that the dimension is
one so i have to justify an h1 equal to
11.
so how do i do it well
i use this formula so
every line
so i have three lines
each of them is with multiplicity three
so that formula gives me a four
so this gives me three times four four
is what you get from this number
and then i have one plane
with multiplicity also three and from
this formula i get minus
one
and this is twelve minus one eleven
that's what i wanted to get
yeah so well
this is briefly our theorem is proves
that
this formula is actually true so the
dimension is actually equal to this so
all the special effects varieties
are actually these linear cycles
whenever s
so
the above
is
true meaning that the dimension is equal
to the linear
deep square dimension that is this
number so meaning that all the special
effects are linear
if
well
whenever s is at most n plus two
and under some bound
when s
is more than m plus two then m plus two
so it's at least ten plus three and this
bounds
is something that makes sure that yeah
it's something that ensures that there
are no
rational normal curves in the base locus
we saw that conics conics are rational
normal curves in the plane they give
they may give speciality so if i avoid
them
by bounding the multiplicities in order
to see no russian normal curve
i
i can prove this so
i'll go back in a few minutes to the
rational normal curve case so let's just
forget it yes so let's just forget it
for the time being and done okay so
so the point is that up to n plus two
the problem is completely understood and
in particular it has some nice
connection with
the theory of modular spaces of
stable rational curves with yeah i have
to write n plus 3 to stay with my
notation so the point is that
capranov identified this modular space
with the project the blow up of the
projective space pn at n plus two points
all the lines connecting the points all
the planes and so on so these are my
linear cycles so somehow divisors in my
setting here in the blown up space
are elements on the core string of these
so that's that's a connection with some
yeah other geometric problem
and then from n plus three and on you
don't have this correspondence anymore
and things become more difficult because
of the rational normal curves so i will
talk about this really really briefly so
the point is that
rational normal curves because i also
promised that i was going back to the
second
varieties so i'm going to write russian
normal curve and their
sequence
are
special effect
so
okay so let me just
reminds that that's a custom novel
because the mobile theorem that
there always exists
a rational normal curve unique
a rational normal curve
through
n plus three
point general points
pvn
so i know how to find the rational
normal curve that passes through my
points
and then i can give a base locus
lemma in the same fashion as for the
linear stuff for the rational normal
curve so i can compute the multiplicity
of containment
that's for the time yeah that it's just
some number i have no time now to
explain it but i know that it exists i
can just use intersection theory to see
how many times it will cut my
hypersurface
and then and then i can give the same i
i can yeah go on like this and see when
this is gonna give me uh h1 but i'm
gonna illustrate this in an example i
think that's easier so you have to be
big enough in order to that your
dimension has to be big enough in order
to see this phenomenon
so
well one first example we saw in the
first blackboard because when we saw the
cortex in p2 with five double points we
got this conic that was a rational curve
through 5.5 is the magic number for p2
so we got that and that was a special
effect but this will be reproduced in
higher dimension this phenomenon always
always occurs so let's consider nine
points of multiplicity six in p6
and i consider degree eights so well
i know well here there are plenty of
lines and so on because the multiplicity
are big enough in order to satisfy this
condition so there are plenty of linear
stuff but we know them already so
instead of writing virtual dimension
it's very linear virtual dimension
because this is
something that we know already
that we already know how to deal with so
this number is -147
but one can actually
compute that there exists one
element inside there
i don't think you can do it by computer
this is too big but for sure you can do
it by algebraic geometry you just take
bi-rational transformations of pn into
some
some other
what we call cremona transformation and
you can reduce this linear system to
something smaller for which you can
actually compute the dimension i'm not
gonna show how i compute this just
believe me but we have to justify quite
a big number here that is not given by
linear stuff because this is already
counted so
well one can use
the zoo theorem to see how much the
rational normal curve that that passes
through the nine points is contained in
the in the base occurs and it's
contained with multiplicity six
just believe me i mean it's just uh it's
just a intersection number formula so if
it's so it's very natural to think that
it contributes like a line so i'm gonna
that's also a rational curve so i'm
gonna use this formula so if it is
contained with multiplicity exactly six
then i can use this formula to see how
much it contributes and the contribution
is given by 11 choose no sorry 10 to 6
which is 210
it's pretty too much because now i have
minus 147 plus 210 i have to get to zero
i have to go back i need some negative
number but the point is that
okay so i have my rational normal curve
let me just represent it by this it's in
v6
and i know that it is contained with
multiplicity six so now i take a point
like just fix for instance my point p1
one of my base points
and then i take any point q
on my on my rational normal curve and
then i can use my base locus lemma for
linear stuff so i can use my base locus
lemma for lines
in order to compute
the multiplicity of containments of this
line so i just make a point on the curve
which is one of the the ones i fixed and
then i take any other point on the co
and on the
on the curve and this
this is going to be contained with
multiplicity um this six plus six minus
eight is again um
four uh
yeah so it's again four but then i can
move my point q all along the curve
and by doing this i just take all these
lines with fixed p1 and all the lines
going along the curve so what i get is a
cone it's a cone with vertex p1 over my
my rational normal curve so is the join
of p1 with c
and the join is the union of these lines
which are contained with multiplicity 4
but that's a surface so i got a surface
which is contained with multiplicity 4.
so if i use the formula for the plane
and and i believe that this formula is
actually good also for that then i get a
negative number and i get a minus seven
but but i have
nine of them because i only took p1 i
can take all of other all the other
points so i actually now
all cones
i obtained minus seven times nine
so just putting together all the numbers
i have i have left ld
plus
minus nine times seven and this is zero
so yes i didn't solve my problem i have
to get to one
so there's something else but the point
is that and here secant varieties show
up the point is that what is the second
variety to the rational normal curve is
the union of all of lines
given by two points on the curve so what
if i take
q
and q q1 and q2 these are not my base
points these are these are extra points
and i can still
so i know that each of them is contained
with multiplicity 6 because the whole
curve is
so if i take if i take the line
connecting them then it's going to be
contained with multiplicity again four
and if i take the the secant that's
union of all this of all of these lines
and that's a three-fold so now i obtain
that the sigma two
of the rational normal curve
is contained
with multiplicity four
so i go back to this formula i get a
plus
something that is exactly one
and this completely explains my problem
so in general well this was just an
example but the thing that we are
working on now is
rational normal curves and their
sequence and also
joins between curve and lin in this case
it was a point but i can take the join
between the curve and a line and
something else
and and these are all this turn all out
to be special effect varieties so we we
believe that we can solve the problem
for n plus three
by so yeah we have a conjectural formula
that's the obvious one by looking at the
example is the same as that and we
believe that this is true and i want
just wanted to conclude by saying that
of course one can use macaulay too and
solve a lot of examples at the beginning
and actually test that our conjecture is
true and then use induction
thank you thank you
sorry for
maybe just a quick question sorry for
running over time
yeah
his last example i think is really new
before this behavior too i would like to
if you can see just one more more
these are six points in
p6 in p6 so this is sigma 2 sorry 9.9
points in p6
the sigma 2 is a threefold mp6
of the defectivity for the header
surface
of the v8
yes
and also you can go on and take higher
seconds so now if you take the three
seconds so the c the variety of secant
planes and you do the same trick
you can you can compute the mod you can
you have you do have a base locus lemma
for that it follows from the linear one
so you can compute this number and it
multiplicity of containment of the three
secant which is a
dimensional a five-dimensional it's a
five-fold
it's contained twice
and that's actually the only one element
inside here
the 3 secant has degree 4
and it has multiplicity 3 along my
points so the sigma 3 is this linear
system
degree 4 and 3 to the 9.
and if i take it twice i exactly obtain
this and you can get it from this
computation and we yeah and and i really
believe that in any i mean this is just
an example then that's that's how it
works for n plus three points
we are that's yeah i didn't write it
that's a work in progress again with
kiara brambila and olivia domitrescu
well since we're short on time yeah
sorry for